today biographics is going to profile
the famous explorer david livingston
but how could i start this video without
first mentioning
my newest youtube channel called
explored it has more documentary style
videos than
you see on this channel but i think if
you dig this stuff you'll find the
weekly explorations get it explored
fascinating whether it's looking at
countries where insulting the king is a
jailable crime to the use of diplomatic
bags to smuggle cocaine it covers a wide
variety of stuff
new videos on their channel once a week
please check it out through the link
below and do
consider subscribing on paper it can be
hard to say exactly why david livingston
is ranked among the greatest explorers
of africa
objectively speaking he wasn't a
particularly effective missionary and
most of the areas he traveled to had
already been explored by other people
on a personal level he got into frequent
arguments with his colleagues and mostly
ignored his wife and children and yet
his legend
endures even now when the european
explorers who paved the way for
imperialism
not remembered that fondly as one of his
historians put it
at a time when countries are being
renamed and statues are being toppled
livingston has not fallen the cities
named after him
still exist as does blanter malawi's
financial center which was named after
livingston's birthplace
so what made him stand out maybe it was
his inspirational rags to rich's story
starting out in a poor family working in
a cotton factory
and ending with a state funeral at
westminster abbey maybe it was his
utmost
hatred of slavery as he made it clear
again and again that
everything he did in africa had the
ultimate goal of
undermining the slave trade we'll let
you decide for yourself if he was truly
deserving of his place in history as we
make it our mission
to explore the life of david livingston
[Music]
david livingston was born on march the
19th 1813 in the small scottish town
of blantar in south lanarkshire he was
the second of seven children to neil and
agnes livingston
and the entire family lived in a
one-room apartment at the top of a
tenement
building the local cotton mill was the
biggest employer in town neil livingston
already worked there as a tailor and it
was expected that his sons would start
working there too as soon as they were
able
in order to help out the family john the
eldest was the first to do so and he was
soon joined by david livingston
when he was just 10 years old both of
them worked as pieces meaning that it
was their job to repair broken threads
on the spinning jennies this
was long and hard work even by the
standards of the 19th century the mill
opened at 6am and work continued
until 8pm with just two 40-minute breaks
for meals
however the owners also funded the local
church and the school and
david used this to his advantage despite
the long hours he
still went to school for two hours each
day and education and religion both
found a place in his heart from an early
age
this sometimes placed david at odds with
his father who as a deeply devout man
feared that his son's growing interest
in science would make him stray further
away from christianity he tried to
encourage even
force david to read nothing but theology
but it was no use as his son became more
and more convinced that the two
disciplines could be reconciled together
at one point the family abandoned the
church of scotland and joined a
congregational church and this
introduced david livingston
to a few people who would have a great
influence over his outlook on life
first was the american presbyterian
minister charles finney who was one of
the leaders of a religious movement
known as the second great awakening in
the united states vinnie was a staunch
abolitionist who considered slavery a
great sin
and also worked with the underground
railroad to provide runaway slaves with
safe passage to canada
the second was a german lutheran named
carl goodslov who
became one of the first protestant
missionaries to the far east
after reading a pamphlet of his asking
for medical missionaries to travel to
china
david thought that he finally knew how
to continue his scientific interests in
a way
that would satisfy his father he would
study medicine
and then become a missionary in 1836
david livingston had saved enough money
to enroll as a medical student at
anderson's university in glasgow known
today as the university of strathclyde
while there he also studied latin and
took divinity courses by ralph wardlaw a
prominent scottish clergyman and another
fervent anti-slaver in 1838 livingston
was accepted as a member of the london
missionary society or lms
before being able to travel on a mission
he first had to do a probationary year
of scriptural studies
in essex in order to become a minister
livingston wanted to go to china but the
outbreak of the first opium war in 1839
put an end to that ambition the lms
suggested that he travel to the west
indies instead but he soon
had other ideas in 1840 he met robert
martha another lms
missionary who had recently returned
from africa the two became friends and
mother excited the young livingston with
tales of his missionary work in south
africa moreover morphat expressed his
beliefs that
through the spread of christianity and
the establishment of legitimate trade
networks they could undermine the slave
trade that was rampant on the continent
this convinced david lippingston once he
was ordained and became a medical
licensure
he wanted to go to africa
on december the 8th 1840 livingston set
sail for africa
his destination was kuraman the mission
founded by
robert marfat in the northern part of
south africa after a slight detour to
rio de janeiro caused by powerful winds
the new missionary touched ground in
africa in march 1841. he spent a few
weeks in cape town getting accustomed to
his new surroundings he finally arrived
in kuriman by the end of july
the missionaries mainly interacted with
the bakuena people established a couple
of hundred miles to the north of kuriman
livingston made several trips to meet
them stayed with them for weeks at a
time and within a year he was fluent in
their language called satsuanga
a couple of years later livingston
founded a new mission at mabotza and
relocated there kuroman was once again
in the hands of robert martha who
also brought along his eldest daughter
mary she in livingston became close and
the two married in 1845 going on to have
six children together despite his lofty
ambitions his good intentions and his
long-lasting fame
david livingston was not a good
missionary objectively speaking
after all the main purpose of
missionaries is to convert people to
christianity
and the total number of converts
attributable to livingston is
one his name was cecele and he was the
chief of the baguana people living in
what is today botswana
he showed a great interest in
livingston's biblical teachings but
there were two obstacles standing in the
way of his baptism first was the fact
that cicelo was a rainmaker
a practice deemed too similar to
witchcraft by the missionaries second
and more importantly
was the fact that as tribal chief cicely
had five wives and again this was
considered problematic for a christian
but in the end cicely agreed to give up
rainmaking and
divorce four of his wives and livingston
baptized him in 1848.
the conversion didn't take it was later
revealed that the chief never really
broke off contact with his ex-wives when
one of them became pregnant livingston
had no choice but to denounce him but
even so cicely never abandoned his new
faith
he kept preaching to others about
christianity for long after livingston
left and one could argue that he was a
far more effective missionary
than livingston himself as far as the
scotsman was concerned he was ready to
move on deeper
into the heart of africa he had heard
people speak of a lake located in the
far
interior he was referring to lake nagami
but in order to reach it he would need
to cross
the kalahari desert it took livingston
several tries to accomplish his goal
his first journey in 1849 was relatively
easy going he picked the right season to
cross the kalahari and had
plenty of supplies and men to help him
his party left in may and followed the
pateti river until it reached lake
negami livingston wanted to cross the
lake and make contact with kololo people
and
their chief sebat wayne however for this
he needed a boat and he did not have a
boat so
his party returned home a year later
livingston made the journey again this
time bringing his family along however
two of his children fell ill
so they had to go back once more he was
ready for a third attempt by 1851. this
time bolstered by
a 25 guinea prize from the royal
geographical society or rgs for
discovering lake negami livingston
risked everyone's life taking a shortcut
across the desert but this time he was
successful the missionary managed to
reach sever twain shortly before the
chief died of pneumonia so lewiston's
original plan it went out the window but
now he had another idea he had heard
about a great river one that led all the
way to the eastern coast of africa
on august 4th 1851 he arrived at this
waterway
known as the zambezi he then thought
back to what moffatt had told him
years ago if they would be able to
establish an effective route for the
legitimate trade of english goods
this would undermine the slave trade
something which livingston still
considered his most important goal but
in order to accomplish this he would
need to cross
the zambezi
this is when david livingston's career
as an explorer started in earnest he
sent his family back to britain as the
journeys would be too dangerous for them
he secured the aid of secular to
sebatuan's son and successor who was
eager to establish a trade route to
luanda
in modern day angola in november 1853
livingston and his party began their
voyage up the zambezi river
and into angola it proved to be a
difficult trek once the rainy season had
started the expedition could no longer
travel by canoe and
had to ride oxen party members were
stricken by malaria livingston included
as were many of their pack animals
the explorer became completely reliant
for communication on interpreters
provided by secalettu as he left the
region where people spoke satsuana
and that was the only african language
he understood everything was more
expensive than
anticipated and the expedition had used
up most of its trade goods
way sooner than they had planned despite
all these obstacles a tired and sickly
livingston reached luanda
on may 31 1854. he was in such bad shape
that a british commissioner in the city
tried to send him back to england
but the explorer refused he thought that
a water route down the zembasi to the
east coast might be more accessible
so that is what he wanted to try next
after a period of convalescence and a
return trip to botswana
livingston was ready to set off again he
departed in november 1855 again
assisted by cecaletto who provided his
expedition with men and resources
during his travels it is believed that
david livingston became the first
european
to set sights on a giant waterfall which
the locals called
mossy au tunia meaning the waters the
thunder livingston renamed it
victoria falls in honor of queen
victoria although both names are
officially recognized today this voyage
went considerably smoother than the one
to the west on march the 2nd 1856 the
expedition reached the portuguese
settlement of teat where most of the
party members stopped the only ones who
continued on were livingston and his
chief guide and interpreter
sequibu whom the explorer described in
his diary
as his right-hand man livingston had
promised to take sequibu to britain and
that was their next destination the duo
continued canoeing down the zambezi
until may
when they reached the seaport of cuellar
maine today in mozambique
thus david livingston might have become
the first european to cross
southern africa from west to east
although to put this in perspective many
african and arab traders had
already done this journey in july the
pair left for england but tragedy struck
on the way while traversing
some rough seas sequibu fell overboard
and drowned
livingston himself had arrived in kuala
many poor hell stricken by fever so
he first stopped on the island of
mauritius to recuperate before
setting off for the long journey home he
arrived in southampton on december 12
1856 and quickly discovered to his
surprise that he had become a minor
celebrity
unbeknownst to him the rgs had published
the letters that livingston had written
to him
presenting his voyages and had already
awarded him their gold medal
he was given a reception by the royal
geographical society followed closely by
another one
from the london missionary society
livingston's fame grew the following
year when he wrote a more detailed
account of his travels and
published it under the name missionary
travels and researchers
in south africa the title might not have
been too pithy but the book became one
of the best-selling travel journals of
its time
and led to multiple speaking engagements
for livingston by the end of the year
the explorer had become a national hero
in 1858 he was named a fellow of the
royal society and obtained an audience
with queen victoria he was given the
task
of leading a second zambezi expedition
although this one had the full backing
of the british government
livingston was given a large grant a
team of scientists and even a steamship
to travel on the river the goal was just
what the scotsman was hoping for to
investigate the feasibility of british
commerce on the zembasi which would have
a crippling effect on the slave trade so
in march 1858 david livingston set off
once more for africa
this trip did not go as well as the
first one exposing livingston's
limitations as a leader in charge of a
large scientific expedition
more dangerously though the scotsman
wrote in his diary about his belief that
his mission
was under divine providence convinced
that everything he did was guided by a
higher power therefore he refused to
admit to
any mistakes and did not tolerate
criticism from his companions which led
to a very strained working environment
indeed many of the other members of the
expedition either abandoned livingston
or
died before the journey's end the team
physician sir john kirk put it plainly
when he wrote
i can come to no other conclusion that
dr livingston
is out of his mind and a most unsafe
leader
but let's start at the beginning the
second zambezi expedition left england
on march
10 1858 bought the steamship pearl it
was carrying a smaller steam launch
christened
the ma robert which was how the african
locals referred to mary livingston
she was also on board by the way but she
stayed behind in kuroman as
she was pregnant once more once they
reached the zambezi the first thing they
did was
realize that the pearl was too big to
use on the river so they had to rely
entirely on the launch this was also
when the first man abandoned the mission
after having a falling out with
livingston
it was norman bettingfield the steamship
captain this
however was still only a minor
inconvenience the true setback came when
the expedition reached the cabrabasa
rapids
everyone else saw them and concluded
that they could not be navigated but
livingston refused to admit this
and simply said that they needed a more
powerful boat
he would have been aware of the rapids
from his first trip if not for the
detour he made to teat which caused him
to inadvertently skip over them despite
his dismissal of the turbulent waters is
only a minor obstacle livingston began
looking for an alternative route which
he believed he found
on the shire river again he encountered
rapids and again he concluded they could
be easily traversed in a proper
steamship the team carried on
on the shire river until they reached
lake nyasa in september of 1859.
by this point two more men had abandoned
livingston richard thornton the
geologist and thomas baines the
expedition artist
originally the mission was only supposed
to last two years there were only a
handful more months left until the end
but livingston wasn't done as he wanted
to try another water route into the
african interior
on the ravuma river so now he had
nothing to do but wait and see if the
british government would extend his
mission and
more importantly replace the battered
and broken ma robert with a new
ship the team engineer george ray also
left and went back to england in march
of 1860 when the original mission had
finished livingston's request was
begrudgingly approved and a new steam
named the lady nyasa was built and
shipped to africa this took a long time
though and it wasn't until january 1862
that the explorer received his new
vessel the ship
came in parts though and it took another
four months to put it together his wife
came along on the second ship
that brought the steamer but their
reunion was short-lived mary livingston
fell ill with malaria
and she died on april 27 1862
david livingston was stricken with grief
but was determined to press on
regardless the lady nyasa was ready to
go in june but by then the river was too
low to allow for safe travel
he still wanted to continue though and
decided to use sailing ships to traverse
the shallow waters this was what
prompted kirk to write that livingston
had lost his mind and
indeed this idea was dangerous enough
that it finally caused livingston to
admit to a mistake
and convinced him to turn around the
year 1863
wasn't much more productive as many crew
members were sidelined with malaria or
dysentery a letter from london
officially put an end to the expedition
and livingston began making preparations
to return home
he took the lady nyasa to zanzibar and
from there he traveled across the ocean
to bombay
where he sold it and made arrangements
to go to england this return
was nowhere near as celebrated as his
first the government had spent around 30
000 pounds on the expedition funding it
for over six years even though
less than a year and a half of that time
consisted of actual river exploration
overall the results were considered
below expectations and the mission was
deemed a failure
[Music]
despite the poor reception to his last
trip david livingston wanted to return
to africa
for a third time however now he found it
much more difficult to secure
funding in order to garner interest for
the expedition livingston sought to
answer one of the most
burning scientific questions of the day
what
was the source of the nile in 1862
fellow explorer john hanning speck
discovered that lake victoria was the
source of the white now one of the two
major tributaries of the nile but
it was hardly a settled matter other
scholars livingston included believed
that there was
another source closer to the zambezi
after a few years he
managed to secure another grant although
this one was a more modest two thousand
pounds
five hundred pounds from the government
500 from the royal geographical society
and a thousand pounds more from private
sponsors his official title was
roving console a position that came with
no salary
and no pension david livingston set off
for africa once more in january 1866 not
knowing back then
that he would never return he was the
only european on this trip he recruited
all his helpers in india
and africa his intention was to travel
first to lake bang wai-lu and then to
lake tanganyika to see if there were any
links between them because of limited
funds the rainy seasons tropical
illnesses and local wars
progress was extremely slow as the years
passed his supplies dwindled and
livingston noticed that they were
getting smaller
with each new shipment the year 1871 was
particularly traumatic by then
livingston was in poor health and
out of supplies and he had to turn for
help to the men that he despised most
the arab swahili slave traders what was
more shocking
was that he started to like them they
nursed him back to health and
sent him cooked food every day and
listened while he taught them about the
bible
all of this is new information by the
way discovered only a few years ago
thanks to spectral imaging in his
officially published journal livingston
omitted some of the more unfavorable
parts of his journey these entries come
from his personal diary which for almost
150 years was considered illegible
that's because livingston had run out of
paper and ink and instead used berry
juice to write on an 1869 copy of the
standard newspaper the juice had almost
completely faded away but thanks to
spectral imaging
the writing became visible once more
anyway back to the doctor because he was
reminded in a very brutal way that just
because the slavers were nice to him
a white british scientist did not in
fact make them nice people
on july 15 1871 he was witness to the
niyangwu massacre when
slavers attacked and killed around 400
magnema people
most of them women who were attending
the local market livingston described
the event as the most terrible scene he
ever saw
and expressed a great shame for
associating with these men
from then on he retreated to a town
called gigi and his diary ended
soon after
[Music]
meanwhile the western world was unsure
of what had happened to david livingston
his last communication with them
occurred in 1869. some thought he had
died but
others were convinced that he was still
somewhere out there in a remote part of
africa
this gave an idea to american media
magnate james gordon bennett jr owner of
the new york herald
he wanted his paper to run a campaign to
find dr livingston for this purpose he
hired welsh explorer sir henry morton
stanley who
traveled to africa in search of a
scottish counterpart it took two years
but in november of 1871 stanley entered
ugi
carrying an american flag and greeted
the former missionary
with the famous phrase dr livingston i
presume
stanley's arrival brought some renewed
determination to livingston who was
ready to resume his explorations
despite being in poor health the
welshman tried to persuade him to return
to england but this proved to be in vain
so
instead the duo explored the northern
end of lake tangica together and
found no connection to the nile
afterwards stanley returned to america
and published a book about his journey
entitled
how i found livingston meanwhile the
scotsman set a new mission for himself
which was to explore
the lulaba river in search of a link to
the nile this however proved to be
impossible given his physical state
livingston was suffering from fever
bleeding and terrible back pain
and by early 1873 he could not walk on
his own anymore david livingston died
on may the first 1873 aged 60. we don't
know if these were his last wishes
but two of his most trusted companions
chuma and susie
took out his heart and buried it under a
tree near the spot where he died
where the livingston memorial is located
today the rest of his body was embalmed
and shipped to britain
back home david livingston received a
stately funeral at westminster abbey he
was once again
a beloved national hero thanks partly to
the new york heralds campaign and
stanley's book but also due to his death
in the line of duty he perfectly matched
up with the ideal image of a victorian
explorer
and has remained popular throughout the
centuries despite his many failings
and even to this day he has hailed as
among history's greatest britons so i
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to check out that new channel i
mentioned at the beginning of the video
explored i am linking to it below
and thank you for watching
you